[Music]  HOSA James is engaged on Sunday he  shared this photo kissing his now fiance  Jeff Leatham in front of a stunning  fireworks display with the caption I  said yes I've known Jeff forever and  he's just amazing and I think they're  gonna be really happy and I'm excited  for them Nancy O'Dell sat down with Cher  two weeks ago who seems to know about  the engagement ahead of time and sent  this message to her friend at Jeff all  right this is for you you know what it  is you know what you're supposed to do  now and this is going to be the best  thing ever and you have to call me to  tell me how it worked out all right so  Colton and Jeff first ignited dating  rumors around Valentine's Day when  Haynes shared photos of the two  embracing congratulations to the happy  couple  you